should accept yourself just the way you
are what does that say about who I
should become is that just now off the
table because I'm already good enough in
every way so am I done or something get
the hell up get your act together adopt
some responsibility put your life
together develop a vision unfold all
those manifold possibilities that lurk
within be a force for good in the world
and that'll be the adventure of your
life
[Music]
kids are being led to believe and
parents are being led to believe that
you can step in with these very powerful
medications these hormones
and you can deny biology and you can
pause biology you can create a Persona
of the opposite sex without paying a
huge price that is the lie that's being
told
that you're not going to pay a price for
this oh yeah there might be a few side
effects no no no I mean like a whole
missing forearm for example and a penis
that doesn't work and and sterility and
lowered voice and decreased bone density
and the increased probability of the
development of cancer and no evidence
whatsoever that there's any any mental
health benefit and all the trauma that
you put your family through and all the
regret that's going to emerge later in
life when you find out that you're
sterile no ability to breastfeed and
complete loss of erotic sensation in the
nipples and
etc etc you mean those risks those
trivial by the wayside risks that are
completely ignorable given all the
Euphoria you're going to experience when
you put your hand self in the hands of
liars and butchers I mean that story
[Music]
thank you
hello everybody I'm speaking today to Dr
Miriam Grossman who I first encountered
as a consequence of watching Matt
Walsh's documentary what is a woman
where she made quite a spectacular
appearance Miriam Grossman MD is a
physician author and public speaker she
has been vocal for many years about the
capture of her profession Psychiatry by
idologues leading to dangerous and
experimental treatments on children and
betrayal of parents
as I said Dr Grossman was featured in
The Daily wires hit documentary what is
a woman she's the author of four books
and her work has been translated into 11
languages
after graduating with honors from Bryn
Mawr College Dr Grossman attended New
York University med school
completed an internship in Pediatrics at
Beth Israel Hospital in New York and a
residency in Psychiatry through Cornell
Medical College followed by a fellowship
in Child and Adolescent psychiatry
Dr Grossman is board certified in
Psychiatry and in the sub-specialty of
Child and Adolescent Psychiatry and so I
thought it would be interesting
especially given our shared interest as
well in clinical issue matters because
Dr Grossman is a practicing uh clinician
I thought it would be interesting to
have a further conversation so that's
what we're doing today she wrote you're
teaching my child what back in 2009
which is pretty damn early all things
considered and she has a new book coming
out later this year it's already
available for pre-order you can check
that out in the in the video description
via URL link there it's called Lost in
Translation a child psychiatrist guide
out of the madness and so out of the
madness that's pretty uh forthright
terminology you might say so
um why don't we start on the
biographical side a bit you started to
become concerned about the issues you've
been writing and speaking about well
obviously before 2009 because you wrote
a book in 2009 and that usually takes a
year or two and so you're an early
Observer of things going seriously
sideways on the clinical front and so
let's go back to well the the the decade
of the 2000s what were you seeing and
why do you think you were concerned
about it when so many of your colleagues
my colleagues well are still not
concerned about it let's say yes well
what happened is that I was researching
uh sex education and what young people
are taught in their sex education and I
was doing that because I was working
with students at UCLA at the time and
there was such an alarming degree of
sexually transmitted infections and
abortions and and so on that I I was
curious to know exactly what kids are
being taught about sexuality and
uh I was quite shocked to see uh what
they were being taught but one of the
things that that shocked me I think more
than anything was I discovered this uh I
like to call it a a belief system or an
or an ideology of gender uh that kids
were being told
uh you know that there's that there's
something called gender which is
separate from sex and it's sort of like
a psychological sex and that a person
can uh uh have a gender that's at odds
with their physical
reality and that that is normal and
healthy and in fact it's wonderful to
explore what your gender might be and so
on and so forth all the things that that
we know about that are being said right
now
and that that I mean I I just couldn't
believe it I couldn't believe that
um first of all uh you know it it's not
so you you cannot simply
um claim that that you can divorce your
identity from your physical reality and
all that is just all fine and good
um that's dangerous and and I knew from
the second that I saw it
I was very concerned about the um the
destabilizing and confusing effect that
that would have on young people
I mean right I mean we we want
as you know in Psychiatry and psychology
we want people to have a stable identity
people want to know who they are
they don't want to be confused about who
they are and they certainly don't want
to be confused about something as
important as whether they're male or
female
and so when I when when the pronoun
legislation came out in Canada
bill c-16 which mandated
gender ideological related pronoun usage
well in personal conversation I told the
American or the Canadian Senate
that that would cause enough confusion
to produce uh uh psychological epidemic
among young women because the literature
on that's quite clear going back several
hundred years and it I think you can
make a pretty strong case and you do
this to some degree in your book in
chapter seven that there are few more
fundamental perceptual categories than
male and female
I think they might be that category
system might be as fundamental as up or
down and or black and white or light and
dark those would be the only ones that I
can think of that are in the same at the
same depth of of cognitive necessity
perceptual necessity you know one of the
things that people tend to think when
they think casually is that if you have
more choice you have more freedom and
more choice and more freedom is always
good but the problem with that is that a
plethora of choice so excess Choice
excess option produces not Freedom But
anxiety because there's only a limited
amount of information that you can deal
with at any given moment and if people
are put in a situation where everything
is up for grabs they're not free they're
terrified and that's part of the reason
as far as I can tell why rates of
depression and anxiety among young
people have skyrocketed recent years
especially among young women who who are
also the ones who are most likely to
fall prey to psychological epidemics in
general and the one that we're in now
specifically so
and I certainly agree with that
um and especially when one of those many
choices that we're providing to young
people is to deny reality so it's not
just that we're providing them with too
many choices you know like when you walk
down this cereal the cereal aisle and
there's like 200 different kinds of
cereal and you get dizzy from it that's
not what we're talking about we're
talking about one of the options here is
to actually deny reality and not it's
not I would even go further than that
there's a there's there's a celebration
of denying reality there's a celebration
of being confused now you'll note that
in the uh you know that that that
lgbtq
uh includes that cue and I think that's
very important to look at when you
include the letter Q in the list of
different identities lgbtq and then plus
the Q stands for questioning
now since when can questioning actually
be an identity and I the the the the the
meaning of identity is that it's
something that is more or less fixed
not that it's something that's a big
question mark
[Music]
inflation has consequences as the FED
raises interest rates to combat out of
control government spending long-term
bonds are diminishing in value which is
crippling the banks depositors are
holding their breath and investors are
bailing on Bank stocks diversification
has never been more important the recent
surge in gold prices is directly tied to
an extremely volatile Market that is why
gold has historically been a great hedge
against the stock market and against
inflation trust the experts at Birch
gold group to help you diversify into
gold text Jordan to 989898 to get a free
info kit on gold Birch gold will help
you convert an existing Ira or 401K into
a tax sheltered Ira in physical precious
metals with an A plus rating with the
Better Business Bureau thousands of
happy customers and countless five-star
reviews you can trust Birch gold to
protect your future text Jordan to
989898 to get your free info kit on gold
today then talk to one of their precious
metals special that's Jordan to 989898
today
well identity we it would be useful to
delve into that too because people don't
really understand what an identity does
and we have lapsed into this idiot
subjectivity that's predicated on the
assumption that you are whatever you
feel now first of all that's a very bad
measurement from a scientific or
clinical perspective because you never
rely as a good clinician merely on what
people feel you need multiple converging
sources of evidence to make a diagnosis
but the second part is more relevant
which is that your identity is actually
a framework of attentional
prioritization and action that enables
you to function well in the natural and
social environments you could say the
psychological natural and social
environments and what you feel you are
is not going to be a useful identity if
it's not integrated with other people
you know
Piaget pointed out for example that
developmental psychologists the children
have to integrate their
ability to play in a social context they
have to negotiate an identity even when
they're just playing a game with their
friends and identity itself is socially
negotiated which the lefties should know
because they're all bang on about
constructivism constantly and so the
idea that's identity is only subjective
and that it's only defined by what you
feel is unethical that's an unethical
stance for clinicians to adopt but it's
also completely impractical because your
identity is the game you play with your
intimate partner it's the game you play
with your family it's the game you play
with your community like you have to be
nested socially at multiple levels of
the social hierarchy in order to have a
functional identity and then to replace
that with merely what you feel and to
enforce that by Fiat
well the only thing that could be more
counterproductive than that is uh as you
pointed out an identity that's only
based on questioning which is just a
pathway to you know existential angst
and hopelessness
well we have to acknowledge that aside
from being unethical and confusing it's
extremely dangerous
because yes and we we we have to always
keep that in front of us you know I
spend a lot of time talking with
families parents kids and uh people who
have been through this ordeal and so I
always have in front of me Dr Peterson
there
their faces and their words and
one of the reasons that I wanted to do
this interview with you
is to give those people a voice there's
a whole population of individuals and
I'm speaking here people have already
talked about the detransitioners and you
had Chloe Cole on which was amazing but
I want to speak about a different
population and that is the parents
the parents of these young people who
have fallen into I'm going to say this
this darkness and this this confusion
um these parents uh are are are
traumatized
and let me tell you let me just tell you
a little story I
a few years ago
um I joined I joined a uh support group
an online support group of parents uh
who were new who's whose kids had
recently announced that they were the
opposite sex or neither sex and you know
there are these these private Facebook
groups and other groups that that
parents attend and they generally are
Anonymous and they have to be vetted and
you know there's there's this huge
process that they have to go through
that takes weeks and weeks in order to
get the support that they need
um because our profession the mental
health profession is not giving them our
profession is demonizing them
so they demonizing you're saying you're
saying demonizing the parents who are
concerned about what's happening to
their kids on the gender education front
yes the the parents that will not
immediately you know jump into
affirmation and that are a feeling of
very strongly that this is not you know
the real issue that the real issue is
that the child has underlying trauma or
Autism or anxiety or what have you the
real issue may be that the family has
had a lot of you know there's been
crisis or there's been losses or deaths
or covet or what have you and the family
is saying look my child is now saying
that you know that they're transgender
but I really feel that there's other
things going on here why are you
immediately giving us a referral to an
endocrinologist for for blockers and
testosterone and those parents are are
are traumatized because
well the traumatized for lots of reasons
okay let's let's list their their
traumas and I have a whole chapter about
this in my book because honestly Dr
Peterson I am so
troubled by the by how these parents
have been treated and are being treated
by the mental health profession by the
medical profession
yep by them yeah well well you know the
most common
problem that I've seen emerge out of
that is this so the American
Psychological Association announced in
its its guidelines for gender affirming
care that there were no valid long-term
studies of the psychological
consequences of transitioning and they
attributed that to
um the Prejudice on the part of
clinicians and researchers against the
trans Community which is of course
absolutely Preposterous
um uh accusation but
be that as it may but then three or four
pages later they said well you know the
evidence is very clear that if you don't
help people transition early that their
mental health outcome is much worse
including the risk for suicide now both
of those can't be true we can't have an
absolute dearth of long-term follow-up
studies on the gender transformation
front because of prejudice in the
research field and know without a doubt
that youthful transition is the best
Pathway to mental health which it most
certainly and 100 percent is not but
that hasn't stopped idiot coward
psychiatrists psychologists social
workers Etc from saying such things to
parents as well
would you rather have a dead trans a
dead
child or a live trans child and so they
put that at the feet of the parents
which is well if you object to this then
all you're doing is increasing the
suicide risk for your for your troubled
child which is about as cruel a thing as
you could possibly say to parents I
can't imagine something more
manipulative and also something so
ungrounded in anything approximating
clinical fact now it is the case perhaps
that a young woman who is troubled
emotionally who takes testosterone might
feel a momentary Improvement in mood
that's a consequence of the
physiological effects of the
testosterone but there's no evidence
whatsoever that that's actually linked
to the gender transition process now you
don't see the same elevation in Mood by
the way as far as I've been able to tell
from the research literature in the case
of boys who are transitioning to girls
and that also indicates that it's more
than likely pharmacological but it is
the case that the medical profession the
counseling profession has been enticed
into this situation and also compelled
by legislation gender affirming care
legislation to outright lie to parents
about the relative risks and you know
like I know that these kids who are
gender dysphoric they're underlying
condition is something in the broader
depression anxiety realm and that the
gender dysphoria is only a it's a
variant expression of that underlying uh
broader psychopathology
so
um look at what if we look at what's
happened in our conversation here just
the past few minutes we can see the
pattern of what is happening on a
broader scale in all these discussions
which is that we always return to the
child now I'm not saying of course we
have to talk about the kids
obviously we have to talk about the kids
but we have to talk about the parents
and what all this is doing to families
it's a destabiling destructive uh uh uh
uh event in the family it's an ordeal
that's that they'll have to go through
for years and years and you know the way
that I'm going to describe it to you I I
don't know if you saw the movie Gone
With the Wind
but there's a there's an iconic scene in
Gone With the Wind and I'm going to use
the description of that scene to help
you understand where I'm coming from so
the scene that I'm talking about is when
Scarlett O'Hara is panic because
Melanie is in is going to have a baby
and she runs to find the doctor to help
with the delivery of the baby and she
goes in order to find the doctor she
goes to this um it's like a makeshift
Hospital on the grounds of a of a of a
train station and you see Scarlett
O'Hara walking through this just
massive area of hundreds and thousands
of injured moaning
you know bleeding soldiers and some of
them are dead and a lot of them are
being carried away on stretchers and
they're they're moaning and they're
calling out to her
well Dr Peterson
that's that's that's what I'm
that's what I'm seeing that's what I'm
hearing all the families remember for
every kid that has fallen into the
gender ideology uh
trap or whatever we're gonna call it the
ideology the pit there are lots of other
people not just parents they're siblings
there's grandparents there's aunts and
uncles and cousins there's a there's a
huge ripple effect
on people
and we need to see that because it's not
only the kids that are the casualties
the parents the parents have trauma and
they are grieving
and it's all
it's none of it is acknowledged except
by each other in these secret groups
that they have
and so what I did about a year and a
half ago I felt so troubled by what I
saw going on and all these people
calling me and well not calling me but
emailing me and you know I the parents
and I I I'd meet them and hear their
stories and see their anguish and
um
you know a lot of their anguish was over
my colleagues my colleagues in medicine
so I felt that I wanted to speak to
these parents
um not just individually but as a group
so I'm in touch with with a lot of the
the parents of rogd kids
and we arranged uh an online
is what
rapid onset gender dysphoria yes
that's the psychogenic epidemic
correct okay so this is rearranged yeah
these are not the kids who like jazz
Jennings for example from the age of two
is you know comes to their parents and
says you know I'm the opposite sex this
is a whole other thing
um this is a social contagion it's
fueled by social media
um Lisa lippman described it I'm sure
that you've had other people probably
discuss that but
um yeah so I did a few zooms with the
parents 50 60 parents
and I did it as much for them as for
myself honestly I really felt that I
needed to say a few things to them
and the gist of what I told them was
I wanted to acknowledge
the the the horrific ordeal that they're
going through I wanted to acknowledge
the trauma that they are going through
real trauma I'm not using that word you
know people talk about you know being
triggered from some little thing and
they get upset you know they got a bad
haircut or something they got triggered
I'm not talking about that their
equestrian hat doesn't fit right the
newest one yeah
okay this is genuine
you know this is genuine post-traumatic
stress disorder but it's not post
they're still going through it
the trauma is ongoing
okay day after day and week after week
and sometimes year after year
so they have they have a stress disorder
and they also have grief from their
losses
and so when I went on to that Zoom with
them I I I and I wanted to recognize
that because my profession is not
recognizing it
and I thought that it was important that
they hear from a psychiatrist
that
that I knew how traumatized they were
and how many losses and how much grief
they were dealing with and that I knew
that my profession has abandoned them by
and large are there exceptions well of
course there's there's exceptions but by
and large
if you look at the mainstream
authorities right the American
Psychiatric association the American
Psychological Association the endocrine
Society the American Medical said on and
on and on we have abandoned these
parents and their children I believe but
I'm just talking about the parents
how do you account for that the fact
that in in such short order all of these
high-level
governing bodies and associations not
only on the psychological front but as
you pointed out on the psychiatric and
medical front have gone full uh have
announced their full support for all of
the presuppositions that are producing
this psychological epidemic I mean how
do you how do you understand that and
and how did you see it make itself
manifest in 2009 yeah
can I can can I want to go just go back
I didn't finish with my talks to the
parents I'm sorry please do yeah I just
want to I don't want to finish that one
part
so
what I you know I I was looking at my
screen
you know at the the grid of of of all
the different the parents that were
listening in
and I said to them that as a
psychiatrist I am acknowledging the
ordeal the terrible ordeal they're going
through and that they have experienced
and are experiencing trauma and when
you're you know your daughter comes home
and her voice has dropped and she's
growing facial hair that's traumatic
and when your son comes down the stairs
to go to the traum in a to go to the
prom wearing a dress and heels and
makeup
that's traumatic
uh and worse of course there's much
worse than those things you know when
you learn that your daughter is
scheduled to have a mastectomy when you
learn that your son is having genital
surgery in their and these their kids
are going to be sterilized and they're
never going to have you're not going to
have grandchildren these things are
traumatic and they are losses
and
I apologized on behalf not that anyone
from the my profession
chose me to to speak for them but I
decided that I wanted to do that
and I apologized
and I looked out I looked at that grid
you know as when you're doing a zoom and
there's a lot of people there and I
noticed that
almost you know more than half the
cameras eighty percent of the cameras
were turned off
I could only see really a few faces
and at the time I I really I didn't know
why that would have been I thought maybe
you know they're in the kitchen or
they're busy or I I really didn't know
and then I found out later on
Dr Peterson
that their cameras were off
because they were crying
huh
they were crying just to hear a
professional
a mental health professional
say to them yeah
yeah
you're traumatized
you you you are dealing with grief with
serious grief just like the trauma of
someone that went through a natural
disaster or 9 11 just like the trauma of
parents who are told their kid has
cancer
no less than that and in fact
more complicated than that because your
trauma and grief is not acknowledged
it's disenfranchised and as you know
disenfranchised grief complicated grief
is much more difficult to live with to
deal with and to heal with
so when you have a a terrible loss and
grief and you can't even share it with
people at work or maybe even
your own family
um and maybe you're you know your other
children are are uh are endorsing the
unreality and are using the new name and
pronouns maybe even your spouse is and
so some of these parents are living with
such deep loneliness in their grief
and I I just feel a calling to to speak
out for those parents and and and to
give them a voice because they are
terrified to be identified most of them
they for various reasons uh they don't
they don't want to be recognized for for
their beliefs uh in terms of their
profession uh they don't they're still
hoping that their child is going to
desist and come out of the gender
confusion and they don't want their
child to be aware that they're speaking
out
so when I speak to parents you have to
understand they're very often in their
cars they're in the basement they're in
the garage they're in their bathrooms
whispering
so you're you're not speaking merely of
disenfranchised grief so we could Define
that as someone isolated who's unable to
pour out their heart let's say to anyone
who's willing to listen you're actually
talking about demonized grief because
the under story here is that
in our current political and ideological
climate if you dare to grieve about the
fact that your child is being pushed
towards surgical sterilization by idiot
ideologues then not only is that
inappropriate it's positively morally
unacceptable right because apparently
this is something that all good thinking
people including parents should only
celebrate and if you oppose it in any
manner whatsoever not only is that
inappropriate it's positive evidence
that you're a bigoted misogynistic
exclusionary you know racist homophobe
all the satanic adjectives you can
possibly imagine are going to be done
and that so it's worse
disenfranchisement
and that you are the reason that your
child's mental health has plummeted
right you are the reason if your child
makes a suicide it is your fault for not
affirming that child immediately and
what I have in my book is how you know
advice for parents on how to deal with
that for example if they have to admit
their child to the hospital for a
suicide attempt how to uh talk with the
staff at the hospital about this issue
when the staff is going to sit down with
them the treatment team is going to sit
down with the parents and say well you
know
you really you have to affirm your child
this is why your child is trying to
commit suicide so I give parents uh very
detailed advice on that conversation
that they need to have with the staff at
the hospital or with this with their
therapist or at the schools you know I
am what I'm trying to do is to provide
parents with the tools that they need in
order you know they're trying to protect
their child not only against the
ideology but against all the
institutions that we used to trust
our schools our Mental Health
Medicine the field of medicine hospitals
you know the list goes on and on
um those institutions that we used to
trust parents need the ammunition and
the wherewithal and the confidence to be
able to go to them and say well hold on
a minute
let me just tell you about
a b c and d and I give them the
information that they need so there is
no consensus on this issue you know
parents and everyone is being led to
believe that there's a consensus on this
issue of how do we take care of these
kids there is no consensus there is an
all all-out uh war going on on a
professional level that that that no one
is hearing about because it's not being
covered outside of people like yourself
and other
you know conservative media is covering
the fact that there is an international
debate going on and that there are
countries who have made a 180 the most
liberal LGBT friendly uh countries such
as Finland and Sweden and and England as
you know have made a 180 in this
direction and so that a child living in
in a Stockholm or Oslo is not going to
be able to get those puberty blockers
and that testosterone
um without in general cannot get them
if they are entered into you know in a
very rare instance uh in which they
perhaps are part of a uh a study in
which they're closely going to be
monitored and watched and given a lot of
psychotherapy and so on and so forth but
but in general kids are not going to be
able to access those treatments whereas
in this country in this country you walk
in and get blockers after half an hour
and this country you walk in Planned
Parenthood Planned Parenthood has been
particularly pathological on that front
they had a gender Euphoria uh promotion
advertising to kids the ease and low
cost ease of access and low cost of the
correct minimal counseling necessary to
start them on puberty blockers which
then turns into hormone therapy which
then generally leads down the Garden
Path to surgery these this advice for
parents is this in your 2009 book you're
teaching my child what to read in your
new book lost translation no no it's
coming up it's coming up in 2009 I I had
no idea that things would explode like
this in 2009 I thought that when I
described what kids were being taught in
sex education using our tax dollars that
they were being taught all this rubbish
about gender and you know born in the
wrong body and you know it's it's a
matter of it's oppressive to be taught
that we are all either male or female
and that we have to break out of that
oppressive uh you know way of thinking I
thought that binary yeah that that
oppressive gender binary I thought that
when I demonstrated that kids were being
taught that there would be you know a
huge reaction
um sadly that did not happen and this
huge reaction is only taking place many
years later when we are being faced with
this terrible crisis okay well so I
thought unless you have another
Direction you want to take this and I
thought we might delve into the gender
issue for a moment both scientifically
and historically I want to I would like
you to tell the audience a few things
about John money for example so let's
say that way but okay but I'm just I'll
say one more thing let's just saying not
the parent I'm very devoted to the
parents okay
we you know uh
everyone is terribly concerned about the
suicide rate among uh kids who are
questioning or confused about their
gender identity and of course we have to
always be concerned one suicide is too
many we're all on the same page about
preventing suicide
okay but no one is talking about the
fact that you know what
some of the parents are suicidal
this whole thing is driving some of the
parents to feeling suicidal and I'm
talking about parents who have gone
through the most terrible things in
their lives
and this issue this particular ordeal
with their child seeing their child slip
away and become someone unrecognizable
both in terms of their personality and
their
uh physical persona
and and in in terms of their future
losses will this child be totally
estranged from the family is this child
going to come visit me when I'm sick in
the hospital uh is this child you know
going to come to their siblings weddings
so you have to understand that even
parents who are who you know who who
went through divorces or cancer or 9 11
or what have you terrible things and
they were able to go through those
things without psychiatric help
without medication
this particular issue
they tell me this is worse than all of
that
and now they do need medication and now
they can't sleep and now they can't get
through the day
the season of Lent might be over but
it's never too late to more deeply
embrace our faith with the crazy leftist
ideologies there is no better time to
start building a habit of prayer and
meditation join me and thousands of
others on hallow the number one
Christian Prayer app in the U.S download
the app for free at hallow.com Jordan
you can set prayer reminders and track
your progress along the way not sure
where to start check out father Mike
schmitz's Bible in a year available on
the Hallow app for brief daily Bible
readings and Reflections or pray
alongside Mark Wahlberg Jim Caviezel and
even some world-class athletes with
hallow you can customize a personal
prayer plan that works for you listen
anywhere you are with downloadable
offline sessions get an exclusive
three-month free trial at hallow.com
Jordan that's hallowed.com Jordan
well I can barely imagine anything worse
than being in a situation where you're
you have a child who's been pressured by
idiot idiologs and potentially your
spouse as well to radically transform
themselves in an extraordinarily
destructive way
in a manner that's going to echo down
the decades that's going to disrupt the
entire family structure permanently and
that's going to turn the person you love
into something like a confused
monstrosity which I think is the most
General outcome that and that you are
powerless and made powerless as well by
the courts to do anything about it and
also subject to the punishment of law if
you dare to voice your anti-transition
opinion I mean that's a pretty dismal
corner of hell though okay so yes so I
also address that I address schools I
have a chapter on schools in this
upcoming book
understanding what's going on in the
schools this book that's coming out
Lost in Translation
is not only a book for parents who have
a child that is currently in this ordeal
it's a book for parents who whose
children are little or who have not yet
been influenced to go in this direction
I want to help parents to be proactive
so that they can dodge this nuclear bomb
and not be ambushed by it parents are
being ambushed by this they don't expect
it they think it's not going to happen
in their family and I want parents to
know that no family is immune
and they must be prepared for this they
have to get educated they have to
understand what they're dealing with
what the ideology is about I prefer to
call it a belief system but
whatever you know what the school what's
going on in the schools in the courts
what if CPS what if the Department of
Family and and services knocks on your
door and they're there with the police
what are you gonna do I have I and I
tell parents what to do when that
happens
what are their rights that's another
experience that's extremely stressful
for families for a family that's been
striving to act in a decent and
appropriate manner to have Child
Protection Services show up on the
doorstep especially with the police
especially when they threaten the other
kids let's say with being removed from
the family and also make a public
display so the neighborhood neighbors
can watch and also set the parents who
are conscientious back on their heels
with regards to grief and guilt for
being accused by the authorities of
doing such things as abusing their
children is that that's absolutely
devastating to people I've I know many
people to whom that's happened and
that's just one bit of the nightmare
that you're describing
it's it's uh
it's unfathomable how bad this is
how evil this is
well so so let's let's delve into that a
little bit so I wrote an article a while
back which I tried to make as
hard-hitting as I possibly could and we
published out in the Telegraph and I
described the people who were engaged in
this on the counseling side so our
professions let's say as liars and the
surgeons who are participating in this
utter greed inspired delusional sadistic
Madness as butchers and called for jail
sentences for example for the people who
were involved which is about as harsh as
I could manage and you know the response
to that column was remarkably positive
uh expect first of all it was published
which shocked the hell out of me and
second the responses generally speaking
were extraordinarily positive and given
that and given as well that you know I
know many of my clinical colleagues and
many many uh clinicians around the world
and it's not as if they don't have more
sophisticated theories of identity than
those are being put forth by the gender
ideologues how the hell do you account
for two things this I asked you this
question earlier the absolute capture of
these once respectable institutions
which is appalling beyond comprehension
but also the unbelievable cowardice
demonstrated by members of the
psychiatric psychological and counseling
communities I mean some of it's
ignorance you know you talk to
counselors now and then who are so damn
poorly educated that they buy the gender
ideology but there's the vast majority
of well-trained clinicians are wise and
perspicacious enough to know perfectly
well that these identity theories are to
call them simplistic and deluded is
barely to scratch the surface but
they're unbelievably timid about coming
forward and so what the hell happened
like how did this capture take place and
how do you account for this stunningly
widespread dereliction of Duty and utter
cowardice
well said well said
okay well
uh this is one of the my goals of the
book also is to educate parents so that
they understand the background
so you mentioned John money of course
this goes back to John money
John money
introduced the idea of gender identity
he coined the term gender identity
and he said that uh the gender identity
is is completely separate from biology
and that it is something it is one's
identity as male or female because back
then of course we didn't have the
non-binary and you know in between all
that you know 47 different gendered
stuff so in the 50s when John money was
writing and speaking about all this we
had male and female
and
his theory was that male and female is
something that is foisted on a a baby a
a child
um by Society
and that it is unrelated to biology
he further said that men and women males
and females have biological distinctions
but they are limited to
um
uh menstruating
gestating and lactating
and that that was it
aside from those three things
uh everything else in terms of
personality and uh preferences for
activities or
um you know cognitive abilities
um emotional Styles perceptions that is
all
uh uh it's a social construct okay
it's all put on the child uh in the
first two and a half to three years of
life and then John money said it's fixed
so you know when you put the pink
blanket on the little girl and the blue
blanket on the boy and then you give
them the toys and you give them
you know you have certain expectations
um based on whether it's a boy or a girl
and all those things the frilly dresses
and the you know the 50s was a time of
course of of uh stereotypes so he spoke
about it in terms of you know the the
girl's gonna be in the kitchen making
cookies and the boy's going to be out
you know fixing the car with his dad and
he said if you take a girl uh uh you
know with ambiguity okay I'm sorry let
me let me go back a minute John money's
specialty his his interest was in
hermaphrodites okay uh very rare uh
babies that are born with ambiguous
genitalia and those ambiguous genitalia
are due to some congenital issue either
endocrinological or or uh or due to the
Chrome chromosomal abnormality and the
baby is born they take a look at the
genitals it's just not clear what's
going on
and that's where the term comes from
this is important
assigned sex at Birth assigned
because in those cases
and these were the cases that John money
became an expert in and he opened up a
center specifically having to do with I
mean his PhD that he wrote in the 50s
was on the issue of sex assignment of
hermaphrodites what do you do it's a
crisis you have to say we had a girl or
we had a boy
and so what do you do in those cases and
you had a special interest in this now
you and I know that when someone has a
certain interest in their life that
consumes them to the point that they
they're writing their PHD about it
they're studying it they make it their
career there's usually a reason behind
it
and it's worthwhile exploring that
reason
now when you look at John money
um
when you look at John money and his
early life and he wrote about this he
was very open about it he grew up in a
uh uh he grew up in a under the the the
hand of an abusive
alcoholic out of control father who
would beat him
and his mother
so John money as a child was not only
beaten
but
watched his mother being beaten
he no doubt had a terrible childhood
and
uh
that that influenced his his image of
masculinity was this monstrous
individual
and he wrote later on he grew up on a
Farm by the way and he wrote later on in
one of his books that he realized that
the world might be better off if not
only animals but men
were gilded at Birth castrated okay so
gelded is the word you know used for
animals so he said that the world might
be a better place if men were gelded
and he also wrote
he said
I
wear
the vile mark
of male sexuality
in other words
we would call that gender dysphoria
[Music]
he's talking about his own body
and he's saying that his
genitals
were vile to him
that is gender dysphoria we didn't call
it then we didn't have a name for it
back then
so clearly John money was uncomfortable
to say the very least with his own
masculinity and his own body
so it's not a surprise that he would
come up with a theory
that if true
would
comfort him on some level
that he is not going to become his
father he's not his father
even though he shares the same type of
physical reality his body
his genitals are are of a man
but
if his theory is true and there's such a
thing as gender which is completely
separate than biology
then it gives John it gave John money
like a way out right right
of not identifying with a monster
have you ever read the fine print that
appears when you start browsing in
incognito mode it says that your
activity might still be visible to your
employer your school or your internet
service provider to actually stop people
from monitoring your online activity you
need expressvpn think about all the
times you've used Wi-Fi at a coffee shop
hotel or even a friend's house without
expressvpn every site you visit can be
logged by the Admin of that Network
that's still true even when you're in
incognito mode
expressvpn is an app that encrypts all
of your network data and reroutes it
through a network of secure servers so
that your private online activity stays
private expressvpn works on all your
devices and is super easy to use the app
has one button you tap it to connect and
your browsing activity is secure
stop letting strangers invade your
online privacy by visiting
expressvpn.com Jordan that's
ex-p-r-e-s-svpn.com Jordan and get three
extra months free
expressvpn.com Jordan
well so you can imagine you can imagine
the psychological impetus there is if
you make the initial assumption that
there's a certain degree of innate
pathological aggression associated with
masculinity and then you develop a
counter theory that much of that is in
fact socialized then there's a root out
of it and that gives him well that gives
him an easy out that that's the thing is
that instead of having to contend with
that internally he can also externalize
that and make that a sociological
phenomena I see this with the the
insistence on the trans activists part
that trans uh identity is much more
common than it truly is and that it's
immoral to interfere with its
manifestation I see that as an extension
of Freudian rationalization you know if
you've taken a dramatic root in your
life or something dramatic has happened
to you you have every reason
to justify your decision post Hawk and
so so let's walk through what happened
with money so he got involved in a very
famous case which he certainly did he
certainly did
um but let's just
uh tell your audience furthermore that
he he wrote his PhD uh on hermaphrodites
and on how to assign their sex uh and
then he went on to open the first clinic
in the United States for hermaphrodites
uh for their treatment including their
surgeries
so he made available
for the first time in the United States
um a place where uh uh there would be
gender reassignment or sex reassignment
including the surgeries and the
surgeries involved castration of course
so we go back to what he said about
being gelded
uh and you know I can't help but think
that on some level he might have been
thinking you know I'm this is I'm
helping these kids
I'm helping these little boys by gelding
them by castrating them and making them
into women
of course they can't be made into women
but the way that he was thinking about
it so
he had his theory uh and he didn't have
any way of proving it because I mean how
do you prove something like that you
until uh until this family showed up at
his doorstep
um and it was a family Canadian family
from Winnipeg I think right
um I think that's yeah yeah
and they were the the reamer family a
blue collar very young couple 20 21
years old
um
and they had a horrific tragedy in their
family which is that they gave birth to
twin boys the boys were fine and when
the boys were well actually they had
phymosis phimosis is a
um abnormality of the um opening the the
opening of the urethra at the tip of the
penis
so the
the boys had phymosis and so the doctors
um recommended circumcision for the boys
and they went in when they were eight
months old for circumcision and uh the
first boy to go in for the circumcision
was Bruce
and the
um
the equipment uh
the equipment there was a a malfunction
of the equipment and they were
cauterizing
the the penis in order to circumcise it
and instead of just that small amount of
tissue that was supposed to be
cauterized
apparently the the uh you know the
settings were Incorrect and the entire
penis was burnt
so Bruce's penis was burnt
um
you know beyond any functionality
so these poor parents went home
the other the other boy was not
circumcised just obviously
they went home and what are they
supposed to do
they have a boy without a penis
what the hell are they supposed to do
so months later
they were
um watching television
and John money happened to be on there
and you have to know also that John
money was an extremely
pompous
um
self-assured individual he was
sophisticated uh when he talked you
listened
um
he came across as being definitive being
you know calling the shots knowing
knowing what was going on knowing the
research knowing the truth
and he
he in this interview on television
said that a boy can be raised as a girl
and a girl can be raised as a boy
if it's caught if if it's done early
enough
and that um
early enough means before the age of two
and a half or three
um and and the parents the reamer
parents immediately
uh took note of that and they thought
here's the answer
this this is the answer for for Bruce
this is what we're supposed to do
so they contacted uh Dr money down in uh
in Baltimore
uh and they and they made an appointment
and took the twins down to Baltimore and
went down there
again you have to understand that this
was a uneducated young blue-collar
family and when they were interviewed
later about their meetings with John
money
um they described him as like we just
thought he was God
we just thought you know this is I mean
he's a professor and he's you know got
all the diplomas and he's the head of
this uh
this this entire clinic at a at an
outstanding uh University one of the
major universities uh in in the world
that was it Johns Hopkins right yes yes
so you have to imagine this young couple
coming and they're at a loss and they
are looking for an answer they've been
praying they're looking for an answer to
their prayers what are we going to do
with Bruce
and John money says well we have an
answer for you
because male and female is actually not
related to chromosomes it's not related
to hormones
it's not innate
we can take little Bruce and
we have to do some surgery on Bruce we
have to castrate him
and we'll remove his testicles he
already didn't have a penis we're going
to remove his testicles we're going to
make we're going to Fashion you know
some sort of
um Elementary sort of female genitalia
you're gonna give him a girl's name
and you're gonna put them in pink
dresses and give him dolls and raise him
as a girl
and you are never ever Dr money told the
parents never to tell him
that this was truly what happened and
and you know after he was born never
tell him because that will ruin
everything
and it's up to you
you have to just work your hardest to
raise him as a girl and make sure that
everyone around him is Raising is
considering him a girl because
essentially he is a girl
and so Not only was this the answer to
the reamers prayers this was as you can
understand now the answer to Dr money's
prayers right right he had an experiment
this was the experiment this was his
proof of concept
his concept
was that being male and female is
completely separate from biology it's
imposed by Society it's a social
construct
and this was his proof of concept
and so
the reamers one huh well he had his
surgery
uh they took him home they named uh they
named Bruce Brenda
they put him in All the Girls clothing
and they gave him dolls and they
you know they did all the all the things
and he peed sitting down sometimes
because as we'll learn later he actually
preferred urinating standing up which is
astonishing
we learned later
that he always wanted to urinate
standing up
hmm
and from the time he was in
diapers
I think
he was told he was a girl
so that really is fascinating but
anyway
um so they took him home raised him as a
girl and uh Dr money started to follow
the twins every year they would come
down for a visit
um the parents would spend time
speaking to Dr money and then the money
I mean the money
there's a slip Freudian slip for you
yeah
Dr money would take the twins without
the parents
into his office and spend time with the
twins
so this went on for years
and Dr money began to report on his
study that became a famous landmark
study
um and he called them uh uh he called
her Joan in his in his study he was
beginning to write about this and
lecture and he was claiming that Joan
uh AKA Brenda AKA Bruce was doing great
I mean uh she was adjusting she was she
may be a bit of a tomboy he he would
acknowledge that but in every way you
know she was adjusting and she was doing
well with friends and with schools and
she liked playing with dolls and she uh
would mimic her mom and he was giving
this glowing glowing report from year to
year and in his um in his uh you know
professional writing of his his studies
his report and he was giving talks
um and he was getting you might imagine
tremendous attention for this
I mean you have to understand this was
by now maybe uh you know the early 60s
this is feminism okay this is the sexual
Revolution this is a time when Society
um or or at least part of society wanted
nothing more to say that male and female
is a social construct
and that in order to gain you know full
equality women have to be considered the
same as men
and
you know to have a study such as this
study of John monies in which he was
reporting that this baby who was X Y you
know normal chromosomes normal
everything biologically but is being
successfully raised as a girl because he
has a girl's name and girls and dresses
and dolls and all you know his entire
Society his teachers and his
grandparents and everyone is reinforcing
the idea that he's a delicate girl who
who who likes to cook and you know is
going to grow up to have babies I mean
this was huge
now
um what happened is that this theory of
John Monies
um became
was accepted
over over the decades we didn't find out
what really happened with the twins
until decades later
um and in the meantime in during those
decades his theory was became Doctrine
okay his theory became just baked into
um you know so many fields of uh both
soft and hard science so that it it was
standard that whenever you had
um for example a an X Y uh or any any
child that that had ambiguous genitalia
if they could be raised as a girl they'd
be raised as a girl so they'd be
castrated just automatically why because
of the great success because of what
John money
um proved to us proved to us and so lots
and lots of boys all over the world I
mean this was written into the
you know the textbooks of endocrinology
and the textbooks of uh genetics I mean
this became a truth so to speak not that
there weren't people uh you know other
other scientists that were standing up
and and saying uh John you know this
isn't proven yet you know let's look a
little closer I don't this is not
necessarily the case but what did he do
he wouldn't tolerate that
John money uh you know was a tyrant he
would not tolerate another uh uh
psychologist or or biologist or
geneticist standing up and trying to
publish something that would challenge
uh his great gender theory he would he
he would arrange you know he would
intimidate the um the editors at the
scientific journals to not publish those
articles
yeah it's a lot of what's actually going
on right now is very similar
right so right um so what happened with
the twins is that uh after decades
uh in fact John money wrote a book in
1997 in which he said yet again
that his twin study
um that his that his gender Theory had
been uh confirmed and supported by the
results of this experiment with the
twins and the following one one person
experiment by the way a one-person yeah
but even that one person it didn't work
okay so in 1990 right yeah so in 1998
um uh
what do we call them now not Brenda not
Bruce but what happened is that we we we
discovered that he he stood up and he
said
he he just blew the cover of this whole
thing was a hoax and he his name was now
David Brenda had become David
and he was not only not only a man but
he was married to a woman with uh and he
had adopted three stepchildren and he
worked as a janitor in a slaughterhouse
right so that was David David reamer and
people can go onto YouTube and hear him
being interviewed about his experience
of what it was like to be told
um for 14 years of his life
that he's a girl and to never ever ever
feel that that was that that was his
truth and and
um what happened is that during all
those years he he was not happy with his
dresses and with his dolls uh he was he
was he wanted to go play with his
brother's tours he wanted to
um pee standing up he wanted to uh you
know he was rough he was he he he was he
was so boyish that and aggressive that
um kids called him uh
cave woman
okay they made fun of him because the
way the way that he walked and his
gestures and his interests were all so
masculine and he was a miserable child
and the and the family was miserable and
on top of everything when he was going
back when the family was going back for
those yearly visits to Johns Hopkins
with Dr money Dr money was sexually
abusing those twins okay how
he was forcing them to undress and
um to uh to mimic sexual intercourse and
he would say you know this is how this
is what men and women do together and he
would you know humiliate them and show
them pictures and the point came why did
they stop going down to Johns Hopkins
the boys refused to go
they refused to go back to see Dr money
and the parents couldn't understand why
they he was quite the stunning creep All
Things Considered now the Johns Hopkins
also closed that clinic down a not how
long after these Revelations emerged
well then that would have been Dr Paul
McHugh who was a is a uh you know a
giant in this area and he had the wisdom
um and the foresight you know to
understand what was going on he uh he he
there were some studies that were done
that would follow up on uh the
individuals who had the sex reassignment
to see how they were doing and those
studies showed that they were no they
were they were they were still really
suffering uh they they weren't they
hadn't necessarily necessarily
benefited from that surgery and that
sexual reassignment so and he wrote
about that in a great book Dr Paul
McHugh his book called The mind has
mountains and he wrote a chapter called
surgical sex explaining how we would be
wise if we pay attention to their
psyches and help them emotionally and
psychologically and not try to change
their bodies so Dr McHugh closed up John
money's Clinic that is true but you know
what the harm was already done by the
time it became public knowledge and and
actually it's not even to this day such
public knowledge unfortunately
um
when it became public knowledge and a
book was written by John colopinto
called as nature made him the boy that
was raised as a girl and it just told
this entire
story from A to Z it's a shocking
shocking story and everyone should read
that book
um
so by the time that book came out in
1999 or 2000
it was already you know that theory was
already baked into
sex education and and you know sociology
and and psychology and
um not I mean look
I have a book Dr Peterson I have a book
that was published in 1998
four kids
I brought it with me show and tell
this book came out
it's called My
my gender workbook
and it has on the cover
if you the picture here is half half a
Barbie and half a Ken
okay obviously a book for young people
and the entire premise of this book
is that
the gender binary
uh is false
that we are not
we do not all fit into this category of
male and female and Mo and they're not
talking about hermaphrodites or intersex
okay
they're talking about none of us
no one fits into it it's oppressive
and we need to rebel against it so
clearly written by the author is Kate
Bornstein an individual who
um
has had a very interesting gender
Journey going back and forth born as a
male then a female then back and then
neither and
this individual Kate Bornstein in 1998
again I'm just I want to emphasize how
long ago
this book was available and written for
young people to challenge them and to
um to to
indoctrinate them with the idea that
Society is placing on you these false
restrictions Society is telling you that
you have to be a boy or a girl and that
is um that that is something that is
it's like racism it's like sexism it's a
terrible thing Patriot it's patriarchal
oppressed yes and we have to break in
its purest form so you know you have to
understand that that this is very
enticing for teenagers who want to
believe in something and want the world
to be a better place and they want to
fight against something they want to
fight against the evil
so this is presented as another evil
that exists in society
so
um you know and this and this book
actually was recommended uh
by
oh gosh
I'm gonna say I'm not sure the American
Psychiatric association or maybe it was
the American Psychological Association
one of those major professional mental
health organizations
way before
um the DSM
acknowledged gender dysphoria was not a
disorder so let me just be clear a book
like this a book like this and and an
individual such as Kate Bornstein who
was had a very active schedule speaking
on campuses public appearances
um you know all over the place being
made into a celebrity
this is all happening at a time when
Psychiatry still considered this a
disorder I mean on paper
on paper not identifying as male or
female and not identifying I'm sorry
with your biology in a way that's
consistent with your biology was still
called at that time of disorder
oh yeah this is 1998. the APA only
changed the DSM in 2013
so this is 15 years before that so what
I'm trying to say is this now did what
happened to David Reimer what happened
did David Reimer committed suicide
eventually didn't he
yeah
yeah yes so that's that's the denouement
of that particularly true and and his
twins so Not only was this a failure it
was a and go ahead oh no it was a
disaster
terrible disaster he committed suicide
and his twin brother died of an of an
opiate overdose
before him his twin died first
the entire family was
you know what
what are the what kind of words what I
mean traumatized it's not enough
trauma is not enough to describe what
that family went through my parents
didn't know a lot that was going on
and if they would have known
that would never would have happened
why me not saying anything
uh the medical community
was under the impression that my case
was a success story
I was shocked when I heard that people
thought that my case was a success story
so so what we should point out here is
that that uh this experiment couldn't
possibly have gone more cataclysmically
wrong than it did right Not only was
what money was saying was not true in
the technical scientific sense it was an
anti-truth and he falsified the data and
it culminated in the death of two people
the demolition of a family and the
perversion of an entire culture that's
and John money's Legacy and and he never
he never publicly acknowledged it
he never publicly acknowledged that um
the twins had uh well that one of the I
don't know what the John money died I
think in 2006 and I think he had
dementia but when the book came out and
uh when John colapinto's book came out
that that just like exposed this whole
Calamity there was nothing from John
money he was still alive he could have
made a statement
nothing
I'm just saying that that's just another
you know
indication of what the morality the
immorality of this person and the you
know the the lack of of acknowledgment
you know of that of what they're guilty
of doing I mean you know I guess it's
too much to expect
we'll be right back first we wanted to
give you a sneak peek at Jordan's new
documentary logos and literacy
I was very much struck by how the
translation of the biblical writings
jump started the development of literacy
across the entire world
the pastor's home was the first school
and every morning it would begin with
singing the Christian faith is a singing
religion probably 80 percent of scripts
memorization today exists only because
of what is sung this is amazing here we
have a Gutenberg Bible printed on the
Press of Johann goonberg science and
religion are opposing forces in the
world but historically that has not been
the case now the book is available to
everyone from Shakespeare to modern
education and medicine and science to to
civilization itself it is the most
influential book in all of history and
hopefully people can walk away with at
least a sense of that
well you were you were making a case a
bit you you were making a case a bit
that part of the reason the psychiatric
and psychological professions the
medical professions did tilt in this
gender affirming Direction was because
money's research was taken as gold
standard and the pathology of that
research wasn't revealed until like 25
years later and so that excuses the
profession to some degree but by by your
testimony as well all of this started to
become pretty public knowledge by about
the year 2000 that the money experiment
had actually gone cataclysmically wrong
and yet what we've seen on the
psychological psychiatric and counseling
Front Medical as well is a doubling down
of the insistence that gender is nothing
but something that's socialized and that
medical transition is the appropriate
move Okay so
it that's all flying in the face of
evidence now instead of being supported
by evidence and so what but you know
what do you have any thoughts but not
only that not only that it became more
and more and more radical so where we
are today and where we are I mean even
this book in 1998 is much more radical
than John money this at least John money
said you know you're either male or
female and that you need and that that's
fixed by the age of three
okay by 1998 kids were being told no no
no no that's a that's an oppressive
false binary it's all on a spectrum it's
all fluid
um and and it's fluid for your entire
life and uh it's wonderful to explore
and to question and no one can tell you
who you are and just a million different
ways it's it's so much more radical I
mean I wish almost you know that we were
back with John money's Theory because it
would be so easy to
um you know defeat
to to it's so easy now we have so much
information from hard science
in fact if John money were living today
he could never he he could never get
published with such a theory that he had
about gender and biology
I mean it it it's ridiculous we have too
much information about the impact of the
chromosomes uh prenatally and uh you
know the the the the impact of hormones
so we we know now that men and women
male and female you know it's not only
different genitalia uh not only what
John money pointed out you know
lactating and menstruating we have each
cell in our in our in our bodies except
for cells that don't have a nucleus
which are very few but every cell that
has a nucleus is stamped male or female
and it makes a difference right okay so
there's a female heart you know the the
we know now in cardiology that when it
comes to for example arrhythmias there's
a difference in the type of arrhythmias
that a woman might get at a PO as op to
a man there's a difference in the way
that
a woman who sustains a very a very
difficult burn how her body might react
to it as opposed to a man and this is
true for every system
of the body so so your point well so
your point is is that not only do you
see a gender difference a sex difference
at the chromosomal level but you see it
at the cellular level and you see it at
the level of systems of cells so organs
you see it at the level of broad
physiology we talked about lactation and
menstruation and gestation but there's
the entire menstrual cycle there's the
completely different effect of hormones
all of that manifests itself in
different perceptual patterns and in
temperamental patterns that are Sex Type
to a large degree and so the point here
is that what constitutes sex is
instantiated as part of identity at
every single level of the hierarchies
that people are embedded in biologically
and then also socially because the
social rules that are assigned to men
and women are not merely arbitrary right
I mean part of what you see with parents
is that the manner in which parents
socialize their children is much more
directed by the children than people had
originally presupposed and so parents
who are establishing a genuine
relationship with their children use the
cues from the child's Behavior to govern
their interactions with the child and so
more feminine girls tend to be treated
as their by their parents as more
feminine creatures and more masculine
boys Etc but the idea that that's all
top-down socialization instead of
bottom-up influence of biology is
utterly preposterous even though human
beings are quite flexible in the manner
in which they can be socialized so well
the thing is kids are being led to
believe and parents are being led to
believe
that you can step in with these very
powerful medications these hormones
and you can deny biology and you can
pause biology and you can uh create
pause yes you can create a Persona of
the opposite sex without paying a huge
price
that is the lie that's being told
that you're not going to pay a price for
this oh yeah there might be a few side
effects no no no no you mean like a
whole missing forearm for example and a
penis that doesn't work and and
sterility and lowered voice and
decreased bone density in the increased
probability of the development of cancer
and no evidence whatsoever that there's
any any mental health benefit and all
the trauma that you put your family
through and all the regret that's going
to emerge later in life when you find
out that you're sterile no ability to
breastfeed and complete loss of erotic
sensation in the nipples and
etc etc you mean those risks those
trivial by the wayside risks that are
completely ignorable given all the
Euphoria you're going to experience when
you put your self in the hands of liars
and butchers I mean not story okay so
this is what parents don't know that
they must understand
and they have to understand this before
their kid comes home and says Mom I'm
not your daughter I'm your son they need
to know this way before that happens
and that's what I want to do for them
yep
now look the the way that the Legacy
Media and the left-wing activists react
to a conversation such as ours is to
point out that we're scared mongering
and that this is this doesn't really
pose a threat to let's say the vast
majority of people and it's of much more
help to the small minority that it's
aimed at than it is harm and that what
we're doing is stirring up fear and
gaslighting and you know all the sorts
of defensive Maneuvers that the radicals
engage in so why do you think it's
necessary for all parents and so this
isn't just parents who have kids with
gender dysphoria why do you think it's
necessary for all parents to be
um what would you say aware of what's
going on in the schools and why do you
think that that's of sufficient
widespread concern so that your concerns
shouldn't be just dismissed as
conspiratorial delusion
first of all let's look at the numbers
just in the past five years
10 years of this explosive growth of
individuals who are coming in for
treatment for gender dysphoria so there
is a hysteria that we're in the midst of
um you know it's it's a wave it's a
tsunami I hope that we're at the the
crest of the wave right now but we could
just be at the beginning
I mean you know just 10 years ago
we had rates of you know one in in 10 to
30 to 100
000 people
with with this particular disorder we
didn't even have numbers it was so rare
let's say 20 years ago it was so rare
for a teenager to present as opposed to
a little kid or an older person it was
so rare for it for I mean even they were
rare but it was even more rare for an
for an adolescent to suddenly come out
with this new identity and with gender
dysphoria so
um those people were so rare just 10 15
years ago and now we have studies
showing you know 10 20 of a high school
class in an urban High School might
identify as not being male or female
so I don't know where this is going is
it you know is it going to 40 percent
um that's why parents have to be aware
of this I would also say uh in in terms
of fear Monger you know the charge of
fear-mongering and it's really only a
minority of people who are going to
suffer
um we have no data whatsoever to support
that no long-term data whatsoever the
data that we do have shows us that the
the regret
uh over this you know massive life
change and these surgeries might take
eight to ten years to develop and oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah and and and I would
add that not only does it does it take
time to develop it takes time to
acknowledge it and to come out with it
publicly
and the research that we do have you do
you have any advice
I was going to say that those people
that regret it they're not going back to
the clinics and telling them there's no
one keeping the statistics on them
they're not coming back to their doctors
and saying how how did you do this to me
they can't sue it's too late
yeah yeah
so why have you got away with it I mean
you know people are counseled pretty
hard and it's really devastating for
people to be canceled like I've seen I
know about 200 people who've been mobbed
for expressing opinions that aren't in
accordance with the radical leftist
ideology most people respond to that
being mobbed and excluded as if they've
contracted a pretty damn serious illness
you know I've seen very well Jay
bhattacharya The Physician from Stanford
who was mobbed for his views on kovid he
lost 35 pounds in three months when
Stanford basically turned its back on
him and I've seen my colleagues hounded
into well into asylums in some
circumstances as a consequence of this
now you've been standing up against this
for a long time and you dared to go on
Mount Walsh's documentary which was you
know quite the provocative move what is
a woman can you tell me that
oh you're at the women's March you must
have some idea please if one person
could tell me what a woman is you are
not here for women we ask you to leave
what is that
um why is it that you've been able to
get away with this and to be so to speak
and to be able to withstand it what's
different in your case do you think oh
no I've paid a price
oh I've certainly paid a price uh
years ago when I worked at UCLA uh my
first book came out in 2008 called
unprotected and I challenged the
political correctness of what was going
on in that student health clinic
oh I was I paid a very heavy price I was
shunned people who I thought were my
friends stopped talking to me after 11
years of very high you know positive uh
annual reviews of my work
suddenly after my book came out I got a
negative review
and eventually I had to leave I left
because I became I was marginalized
so why did you continue
why didn't that stop you I mean look
people often apologize right and they
apologize and they backpedal and you
continued moving forward despite the
fact that you were facing substantial
opposition for your views like why do
you because this is rare this is why I'm
concentrating on it you know lots of
psychiatrists and psychologists and
counselors know perfectly well that the
sorts of things that we've been
discussing today are 100 true they know
it but they will not stand up and say it
now you did and you got punished for it
why didn't you apologize and quit okay I
think there are two reasons I'm gonna
say number one is that my parents were
Holocaust Survivors and all of my
grandparents and and a good pit a good
bit of both sides of the family were uh
were exterminated were were
victims of the Holocaust so I understand
tyranny and I understand lies and I
understand why when
when dangerous people stand up and and
say falsehoods and they are followed out
of um because out of fear and
intimidation I understand that too well
and I would say the other reason is that
I'm a person of Faith deep faith and I
believe that there are
um that there are Eternal truths
and I believe that
part of why I'm here in the world
is to stand up
in my in my small way when I can to
stand up for truth and to
um
protect especially young people in their
families from this terrible darkness of
Lies
okay well that's a good place to end Dr
Grossman I would say
um thank you very much for agreeing to
talk to me on YouTube today and its
Associated platforms for everybody
watching and listening
um Dr Grossman I'll just remind you has
wrote a book called you're teaching my
children what back in 2009 and a new one
coming out very soon Lost in Translation
a child psychiatrist's guide out of the
madness she also appeared on Matt
Walsh's documentary what is a woman
which is where I encountered her work
I'm going to talk to Dr Grossman for
another half an hour on the daily wire
plus platform those of you who would
like to hear the continuation of this
conversation slightly different
direction or more than welcome to do so
show some support for the daily wire
plus people who've also facilitated this
conversation and many like it
um for all of you who are watching and
listening your time and attention is not
taken for granted it's certainly
appreciated and to Dr Grossman well
thank you very much for agreeing to talk
to me today and for well telling all the
stories you told to everybody who's
listening I'm sure there are many
parents out there who are tearing their
hair out in utter desperation who
desperately need something approximating
the ruins of a life raft to cling to and
at least you can provide some evidence
that not every psychiatrist and
counselor in the entire bloody country
or the West for that matter has gone
Stark raving mad and become cowardly and
delusional and so we much appreciated on
that front and I do think the tide is
turning the closure of the Tavistock
clinic in the UK is a big deal
especially given the bombshell
Revelations that emerged in the
aftermath and as you said the
Scandinavians and the Brits have have
have adopted a much more sensible stance
and comparatively rapidly and so I can't
see that the U.S and Canada Australia
and New Zealand can withstand that for
very long so we'll pray you know that
all this Butchery and lies
starts to come to an end relatively
quickly and then if it does well you've
played some Cardinal role in that so
hooray for that thank you
you bet all right everyone we'll see you
well on the next YouTube
discussion or on the daily wire plus
platform
ciao
hello everyone I would encourage you to
continue listening to my conversation
with my guest on dailywireplus.com